for over a month ukraine's president
vladimir zelensky has been leading his
country's fight against the russian
invasion from this complex in kiev
the economist editor-in-chief traveled
to the ukrainian capital to meet with
him to discuss the scale of the
challenge he's facing
and the international support his
country needs to end the war
[Music]
the inspiration you give i think yeah
people are just extraordinary at the
moment i've never seen president like
this in their life it's an extraordinary
change how did it happen
i think that these changes happened
already in ukraine when they elected me
when they voted because they uh the
people ukrainians they understood that
they want
i don't know they want changes they saw
my
honest position to everything
to everything
you have to be honest not to try people
to
believe you
don't try it don't do it
be yourself and maybe maybe when you
will show yourself who are you maybe
maybe people will love you more
than it was because they see
don't lie and and show people who are
you exactly and and
no not to show that you are better than
you are did you know you had this inside
you to be so brave
to be such a strong person i i i it
you know it's it's it's not about uh
i'm brave or or not but you can't say
that if i would be the president of
ukraine or ukraine i would do this way i
understood what's going on so i
understood it
a lot of months ago what's going on
that is very big
history or big story it's not about it's
not only about ukraine it's about the
world about the politicians of the world
and i think we could speak about it
after we win
yes and i hope we win i'm sure we win
that's why i'm saying that
i'm not the hero maybe maybe
maybe i'm not so stupid to understood
what's going on
i i wanted to to change attitude to
ukraine because just just to be
understandable that ukrainians
ukrainians our people that are the same
like people in
in
usa in europe in russia we're at the
same we are on that one level
it's not about who has more weapon or
more money much money or gas oil etc
and that's why we have to have agency
that's what i understood
the the the first thing that i
understood that we are
people have it
people are leaders
and
politician leaders
are losers it's it's what putin does not
believe in the agency of people and what
you believe is yes yes i i believe it i
and i knew it and i understood it and
you felt at that moment on the 23rd or
24th of february that people wanted you
to perform this part or did you was this
a moment when the war started
where
you suddenly clicked and i understood
what to do when when it's you know when
it began
in kiev i was in keno i was seen in in
the house in the residence i was in the
residence and my wife and my children
they told me that
early in the morning it was it was five
or five
four four fifty like
and they told me earlier
then i've got the call from our
staff your wife and children yeah they
told that something something going on
because we heard it very loud and and we
we was we're sleeping and at that moment
you knew straight away
uh we we know we knew about that they're
preparing we knew it of course let's
let's talk about now where we are now
the stage in the war you know is there a
real chance you can win
only vietnam
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
in some small cities we were destroyed
already there are no people
and no houses we have such small cities
we we don't have them only the name
alternative
you've said this you say it to your
western yes it's the best of western
partners you ask for tanks you ask for
jets and yet president macron said this
is a red line they will not cross why is
that when you when you talk to them
you ask for more defensive weapon you
ask for authentic weaponry they say no
because they afraid russia
that's it
and who is
he
boris johnson has been
much keener to send weapons is there a
difference between the willingness of
european countries to help you yes
and what about the germans because on
the one hand there was this saturn
vendor this sudden shift after the
invasion german foreign policy appeared
to change very quickly and yet now it
seems they are already
if not backsliding at least worried
about doing more is that fair look
[Music]
do you think
that actually the west
germany in particular but other
countries as well are afraid
of you winning the war
that the victory the military victory
if ukrainian army prevails
and russian army runs
then
this is kind of a world which they're
still they want ukraine to defend itself
but the idea of ukraine actually winning
and putin falling
ultimately is too
kind of big to imagine
m
[Music]
which of those four groups does britain
come into
you give four examples of countries
which is britain
um britannia
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
are they can i guess that they are in
group one
we'll see
[Laughter]
more seriously but they help
we have to we have to know yes they are
helping because because when we when we
speak about the
exactly weapon etc because a lot of
countries in in europe in need
especially yeah they had
uh many
like our soldiers say many instruments
and that's why the
usa pushed
a lot of countries to to help us with it
but a little bit slowly than we need
what are your top priorities now right
now when people airplanes number one
airplanes
number two but it's number one tanks we
don't we don't have it so much as we
need
as we need and we've got a lot of from
russians you have to know
that they are running yeah they're
running yeah they afraid our soldiers
and they was running i think yesterday
we've got 12 or 17. if we if we can joke
in this situation so i i will there are
some some cities
where they have so much
so many tanks they can't go away
when we begin to shut down yes they
block they have tank traffic
yeah that's
that is true
one question about putin can there be a
lasting peace
with putin in the credits
this is
do you think that fundamentally he
thinks ukraine has no right to exist
ukraine
um
he has a 20th century view of a 21st
century country yes that's it
and that is his problem
yesterday
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
new
is
thank you so much thank you for coming
thank you thank you okay thank you bye
bye all the best
thank you for watching and if you want
to read more of our coverage on russia
and ukraine
please click on the link below
and don't forget to subscribe